so
hey everyone and welcome to another hd
tutorial and in this video um i was
about to do a video on how to change
your fonts in rocket dock which you can
see at the bottom of my screen and a lot
of my desktop videos there's a stock or
at the top of my screen that i have a
lot of my icons in so i maintain a
perfectly clean desktop but then i was
realizing that i didn't show you guys
where to get the themes in the first
place so this video is going to be um a
video on the fonts the website where you
can download and install free themes for
xp for vista for any windows machine
windows 7 any windows operating system
so i'm enjoying this tutorial and i hope
you enjoy the fonts that you may find or
download on the site
alright welcome to my desktop here you
can see at the bottom this is these are
the icons that i was talking about in
rocket dock if you haven't already just
go ahead and watch my videos on
rocketdoc how to download it customize
it install it etc but you see a little
theme that actually the not the theme
but the font that comes up that says
audacity that says sony vegas pro by the
way if you want camtasia studio 6 or
sony vegas pro for free watch my hd
tutorials on how to get those for free
so um we're going to do what we're going
to do is go to the fonts we're going to
go um just open up any web browser that
you may prefer
and uh go to any major search engine
whether that's google or shiny search or
apple or whatever and we're going to
type in defont
and this is the website right here
dafont.com where you can get a ton of uh
graffiti art and calligraphy tons of
different fonts and all these different
styles where we can uh select the ones
that we want so first of all
i have to mention that these are
multiple
multi-platform downloads so you can get
these fonts on mac os 10 and on your pc
so i'm just for any um for the purpose
of this tutorial i'm just i'm not
actually going to go up here but you can
use this search box here to search for
any
style of a font that you might like to
find or i'll look by alphabetical order
or in this whole search guide here but
i'm just going to look at i like this
say i like this font in golden pony so
i'm going to do is click on the download
button to the right of it and you can
see over here it says download warning
this is a zip file okay but what we're
going to be unzipping is the font itself
and windows vista actually has the um
the installation
of a font built into it so we're going
to do is open
and it's going to download pretty much
instantly since it's a puny file and you
can see it's 57.9 kilobytes and then
what we're going to do is open up the
folder in which we just downloaded this
this file so we're going to exit out of
our web browser back here so we can see
exactly what this is this is a true type
file font what we're going to do with
this font that we just got again very
small compressed size is right click it
and now we're going to extract all files
so just hit the extract all files button
and find a place or a location in a
director where you want to install this
font so i'm just going to look through
my documents find maybe a program
documents where i like to save a lot of
my downloads so hold on a second
documents program documents and hit ok
so this is where we're going to um leave
the button check that says show extract
files when complete so you don't even
have to look back for it again it's
going to do a quick extraction and then
open a new window
so you remember the old name of it was
golden pony so we're going to look in
the new file for uh the new folder for
gold and pony
and so it's searching well yeah i didn't
exactly find it there and look for
golden pony so i'm just gonna look
scroll down until i find it maybe you
guys see it already i don't know i'm
kind of blind
but um here it is golden pony as you can
see there are two t's because it's a
true type font once you have this right
click on it and there will be an install
button right here this is a key thing in
windows vista if you don't have this in
xp i promise to put in the description
um a way to actually install this
because you don't have a right click and
install option windows xp but i will put
it in the description how to do this in
xp or 98 but in windows vista and
windows 7 you just hit this install
button and if uac does pop up pop up
like you just did for me just hit ok
so it's currently installed the font is
already installed on my pc so now if i
were to use it and i'll try to pop it up
on a preview for you here but that is
basically it that is how you install
um any font from you want um from
dafont.com again i'll put the link in
the description i'll put instructions
for older versions of windows in the
description and enjoy your new fonts
guys so thanks for watching this one and
if you have any more tutorial ideas or
requests for me again i do tons of
videos and requests and uh support me by
subscribing and help me become a youtube
partner thanks for watching this one and
peace
you